that's not the not the only cool thing
we have exclusively for comic-con this
week we are testing our shows in virtual
reality thanks to our good friends at
AT&T that's right you can watch our show
in VR via Conan cardboard and other VR
devices we have a for conan 360 cameras
placed all over this theater you can see
the show from any angle it's pretty
impressive show Mandy alright strapping
in alright alright let's take it oh hi
Conan yeah oh look at how I look at how
baked you look yeah let's cycle through
the camera so people can see that's
pretty impressive yeah yeah okay there
it is
now this is a good way hey buddy what's
going on pal
hey guys Brittany are you in anyway
what's going on he refuses to
acknowledge it away hi friend
yeah what's your name buddy very nice
clearly someone flee the long arm of the
law a little shy Wow
yeah lose a few
oh hi you brought your luggage okay Andy
you look like an idiot
haha - oh my god I just saw myself I do
yeah it's as if you're in the actual
theater Andy it really is it's so much
more real than actually being yeah now
those of you at home with headsets can
go to Team Coco comm slash 360 to
experience all of this if you like
thanks for our friends at AT&T for
sponsoring Coenen 360 we're gonna take a
quick break when we come back the cast
is Silicon Valley
[Applause]
[Music]